العلاقات المتوتره وطبعا اهلا فيكم من
جديد العلاقات المتوتره ما بين امريكا
وروسيا موضوع لا يخفى على احد يعني اسباب
او تداعياتها وحتى سحاتها كل مالها بتتوسع
وبتزيد اليوم اكتشفنا ساحه جديده من ساحه
الخلاف الامريكي الروسي والساحه هي
التهنئه باعياد الميلاد بعيدا يا جماعه من
مواليد 20 نوفمبر 1942 يعني كمان ثلاث
ايام راح يطبق 80 سنه في روسيا خلال مؤتمر
الصحفيين في صحفي سال المتحدث بسم الله
الكريم لاند لو كان بوتن ناوي يبعث تهنئه
بمناسبه عيد ميلاده وانه يعني مو اي عيد
ميلاد هدول 80 سنه مسكوف رد وقال انه لا
ما بيتوقع انكم
بس المفاجاه مش هون المفاجاه بالتبرير
الاستخدامه
فبيحسب كلام المتحدث
اعيد بايتين بعيد ميلاده لانه يوم السابع
من اكتوبر كان عيد ميلاد بوتين ومو اي عيد
ميلاد كمان كان برده عيد ميلاد مختلف
فوقتها طبق السبعين سنه
وبعيدن ما همنا او على مبدا واحده بواحده
الكريم اعلنها ما راح انها بايظه
بالمناسبه الحديث عن بايظ ان في مقطع
متداول منها مش قمه العشرين لبايدن بيمدح
في عضلات مصور قبل ما يتفاجا بمعلومه ما
كانت على البال ولا على الخاطر
حلوه كويسه
[موسيقى]